I'm a dietitian and I'm going to show
you a meal that I make with three
ingredients from Trader Joe's a little
bit of avocado oil a little bit of
butter
smells like the holidays this in
stuffing we got the famous cauliflower
gnocchi here loading up with six grams
of fiber per cup that's amazing
then we've got our chicken sausage for
protein
for carbs fiber extra veggies and lots
of fiber we've got this sweet potato
holiday hash smells like Christmas it's
gonna add a little maple syrup to bring
out some of that sweetness
a little salt a little pepper we got
tons of fiber in the cauliflower plus
the sweet potato mix we got carbs in
there as well with all the sweet
potatoes and tons of protein in the
chicken sausage as well as some healthy
fats in the avocado oil
it's pretty good